good morning everybody uh welcome to
today's uh training workshop you know we
got some good speakers coming up after
me as well but um you know today i want
to talk about strategies for day trading
with order flow and you know as we've
seen the past week
the markets have been going bunkers you
know we're getting massive moves up and
down in both directions you know
pretty quick you know on
when was it wednesday tuesday night into
wednesday you know we had a 50-point
move just in the s ps
within the first 45 minutes of trading
and i'm going to talk about that move
you know and it's sort of how you could
have used order flow to take advantage
of moves like that and not only take
advantage of moves like that as they're
occurring but as they
reach their apex and the market starts
to turn and form a reversal so
in today's training
you're going to discover why order flow
analysis gives you an edge over other
traders by showing you data other
traders don't see
i'm going to show you how order flow
allows you to see actual strength and
weakness in the buying and selling
that's going on in the marketplace
and i'll give you actionable methods to
analyze order flow that you can use
immediately now for those of you that
are brand new to one of my presentations
just a very quick brief summary of who i
am my name is michael valtos i've been
involved in the futures trading world
for over 25 years i literally started at
the bottom of the industry i started on
the cme floor
with dean ritter reynolds as a runner
and eventually i worked my way up i left
the trading floor when electronic
trading started taking off then i joined
eventually edf man the big english
training company has been around for um
you know over 250 years i'm a licensed
eurex trader i got my license when i was
at commerce bank
um the big german bank uh after commerce
bank i joined cargill i was head of
futures trading at cargill in chicago
and they even sent me out to singapore
to set up a trading desk there when the
exchange floor was closing after my time
at cargill i spent eight years at
jpmorgan as vice president of
futures trading
and these are all trading jobs right
it's not sitting in an office you know
telling people what to do or watching
you know going over excel spreadsheets
and things like that no it's actually on
the trading system
connected to the exchange
and after i left jpmorgan
i
formed my own company order flows.com
where i'm a independent trader as well
as software and education provider you
know we developed a software an order
flow software specifically
for
finding the nuances in the order flow as
opposed to just having software that
formats the order flow so you could read
it you know we took it a step further
and created basically a swiss army knife
of trading tools based around order flow
and you know the reason why i'm telling
you this is because the charts you're
going to see in today's presentation
are
formed using my order flows trader
software now however right if you're
using another software that has a
footprint chart you can use what i'm
teaching you today
on your existing chart but you're going
to see how easily and quickly you can
apply order flow analysis to your
trading to make better more informed
trades because that's what you want to
do now if you stay around to the end
i've got a special treat for you i'm
going to show you how to download
a copy of my book trading order flow i
wrote this book after i left jp morgan
you know i wanted to give back to the
trading community it's 150 pages long
you're not going to get you know the
hard cover that you see here you're
going to get the digital download but
it's really a great starting point
for anybody that's interested in order
flow and in trading in general
now again like i said we created the
software to help making
uh order flow analysis easy and as you
can see you know what many people have
said
you know the order flows trader software
is very helpful because they can clearly
see now what's happening in the markets
right you know another guy says you know
if you really want to trade properly and
understand what on earth is happening in
any markets order flow is the path
forward and with mike's experience and
explanation it clicks right and that's
the whole point of doing these
presentations is to introduce you
to new ideas
new ways to look at the market that
probably you never thought of before you
know and what separates winning traders
from losing traders is not having an
edge but really what is an edge
well it's a piece of information that
other traders don't have or something
they don't see happening in the market
right orderful gives you that edge
because now you have the information
other traders don't have
you know we're living in a world an
information age and that's where you're
going to get an edge so you can be able
to see things happening in the market
that other traders don't see such as you
know market sweeps or market imbalances
or markets getting weaker or markets
getting stronger
now before i jump in you know just a
brief disclaimer do understand that
trading involves risk right you
shouldn't be jumping into the markets
unless you have risk capital which is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing your security
uh or lifestyle and only risk capital
should be used for trading right i know
some people they like to jump in
thinking oh you know i gotta start i
learn how to trade in the next two weeks
otherwise i go get a job you know that's
not how you want to approach trading
right approach trading you know from
a methodical standpoint you know because
if you become good at it
it can provide for you nicely all right
so
in order flow
there are you know three building blocks
and i'm going to go through the three
building blocks which is delta point of
control and imbalances and show you how
you can apply them you know in everyday
usage of the markets now what delta is
delta is the difference
the net difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in a bar
now every bar has a delta right and
oftentimes you're going to see it
on the bottom you know some other
software likes to put it on top or the
bottom i like to keep it neat and clean
and just
show it on the bottom and what you're
going to see is either a positive number
or a negative number if the number is
positive that means there were more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers in the bar if the delta was
negative you can see the first line here
the red area is telling me that's it's a
negative number
then there's more aggressive sellers
than aggressive buyers in the bar
and generally not always generally as
the market is rising it's going to rise
on
more aggressive buying than aggressive
selling
you're going to see positive delta just
as if a market is selling off you're
going to see negative deltas on the move
down now there's going to be times where
the market spins around like right here
right the market just stopped right in
this area
and this is important to know as as a
trader what's going on in this market
right why are we stopping in here well
let's just take it uh break it down this
is from yesterday morning just after the
cash opened
and immediately there's a lot of selling
coming in you can see the strong
negative deltas
minus 900 minus 500 minus 1000 minus 300
minus 1200 right very strong negative
deltas you're sort of expecting this
market to continue selling off why
because you know the aggressive sellers
are in control based on the delta
obviously you got red candles you know
so the price action is down but then the
market just stops
and goes sideways here right and then it
rallies
all right so you know what can you take
away from the delta well i know i've got
very strong selling right i see minus a
thousand in the delta minus 1200 in the
delta now this is an e-mini one-minute
chart
but then
you don't see it anymore right you just
see positive 163
negative 107 negative 291 negative 15.
so now i know that yes i had very strong
selling right off the bat
the selling is no longer there right but
i don't necessarily see strong buying
yet right i see small
back and forth action i see positive 163
i see negative 107.
right then i see 291 negative negative
15 which is very small then another bar
with some strong selling minus 700
okay so some selling is coming back in
but then it follows right back with
another bar with positive delta of 126
followed again by negative delta of 392
small negative delta minus 96 then
positive 28. so in this area right
you're seeing relatively small deltas
except this one bar is plus of negative
772.
but buying is more or less equal right
markets are always trying to find value
you know and
in terms of value in the market value is
an area where people can transact right
where it's sort of a fair price in the
market
here we're out of value right you can
see the market is looking for value you
have more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers then it found an area
where people can transact
and no one's really in control one way
or the other right and you know people
say well you got small volumes no the
volumes are are pretty decent you know
for that time you know five thousand six
thousand six thousand four thousand six
thousand five thousand these are healthy
bars it's not putting in small deltas
you know with basically nobody in
control on very light volume no there's
legitimate volume going through here
then the market starts to rally and
what's the clue
of this market possibly starting to
rally again watching the deltas you know
you're getting in here with this
negative delta negative 96 which is
relatively small a small positive delta
of 28
and then it jumps
450 positive then it jumps again at 744.
so now you know the aggressive buying is
getting stronger
and the market is starting to rally
that's your sign that this market is
going to go up just as the market was
going down on strong negative delta once
you start to string together some nice
positive delta
increases from 28 to 450 you know 450 to
744 that's a clue to you as a trader
that the market is potentially going to
go higher
now again from this is the day before
okay again about a half hour after
the market open the cash market open
this is nine o'clock chicago time 905 9
15.
you notice
the market is just it's going sideways
here right but you got some nice
positive deltas
697 461 332 791 right so you've got some
nice positive deltas the market's going
sideways so you got to be wondering you
know why isn't this market rallying
right because sometimes the questions
that you should be asking
is
you know i have very bullish information
but the market is just
not rallying
it's telling you that there's still some
pressure on the market then you see the
selling come in here right minus a
thousand negative delta minus 331 minus
191 minus 158. so while you have selling
strong selling came in this bar
this red bar here
as you were going down down down down
the selling is weakening so you had some
some decent buying in here okay the
market quite couldn't pull around so
it's telling you the sign that you know
this market could still be weak
and then you saw some strong selling a
little bit more selling but even as he
got more selling it's getting weaker
it's minus a thousand only minus 331
minus 191 minus 158 then a positive and
a negative delta
right my plus 470 minus 446
it which sort of
washes each other out um then 374
1100 789 now you got the buying coming
back in
okay so you had buying here but the
market you tried to rally then it just
got slammed now you're seeing the buying
come back in
okay the market did come off over these
next three red bars and if you're
watching
the you know just the price action
you're thinking oh you know we're going
to go going to go lower
but even though it's ticking down you
still have net aggressive buyers in the
market
231 754
right before it pops up i mean it
doesn't look like much on these bars
even the price action has been crazy
um but you know you're talking this one
bar here is you know a 10 point bar
right 500 move in in one minute on this
bar but you know that the buying is
coming back in here and even though the
market is just sort of drifting down
slightly
it comes right back up and rallies right
so even though you're seeing these three
red bars you know most people will see
oh i got three red candles i get short
but if you're watching what's happening
in the order flow
you see that actually no you know
there's net aggressive buying coming in
here
you know that's probably your sign you
want to get long and think of it like
this
okay it's like being stuck in the mud
you ever been in your car stuck in the
mud or i'm in chicago sometimes you get
i got stuck on my driveway in this on
the ice and the snow you spin the wheels
around a lot and
you can't go anywhere right and that's a
bit sometimes you see that in the delta
right you got the big positive deltas
and you're thinking you know this market
should be rallying and it's not
right that's your sign that hey you know
what maybe i better get out put some
traction you know like put salt down on
the road or you know put a carpet under
my wheel so i can get some traction
because if this market you know if
you're seeing that aggressive buying and
the market is not going higher it's
telling you that there's some you know a
bigger current underway that is you know
affecting why this market isn't going on
going up and you know if anything you
should think about potentially getting
short
or not taking that long
okay
now
delta is going to help you with short
term moves as well this is crude oil
now
what do you see here right you see this
market hit the swing high right but it's
going up
on
negative delta right it's gone up minus
5 minus 61 minus 122. okay now it's sort
of peaked out up here
so it's coming up here
and you're seeing selling come in
well if you come up to a swing high you
see selling come in what do you expect
the market to do well it should fall
over and it did again this is not a big
monster move but it's a move from you
know more or less 87 15 down to you know
86 90 25 move and then it sort of hits
the swing low
sort of going sideways and then delta
starts to pick up 3 9 52 147 and it pops
up again another 25 cents in the crude
you know these are very quick trades
three minutes you know eight minutes
here
and that's how delta is going to help
you it's going to help you see where
there's weakness happening in the market
right here or
some hidden strength in the market right
here the 352
147 minus five minus 61 minus 122. you
know sellers
are starting to come into the market up
here just as buyers are coming into the
market down here
this is a oh this one is a beautiful
example this was on on tuesday right you
have this market hit a swing high starts
coming down sort of bottoms out and then
boom it takes off
now
you know think of it like a plane
landing right you know planes just don't
come in and drop right down you know
they sort of come in you know come in
and drop off their load and then fly off
but as you're coming down in here okay
you're seeing
the delta right minus 31 minus 44 minus
175. so you know it's getting stronger
here okay which so you're expecting to
move lower
because these are negative deltas
getting stronger
you come down in here and these again
you get the big negative delta minus
372.
at the low of the swing move delta is
only minus 70 okay so it's almost like
you know you're coming down in here
sellers put their foot on the gas pushed
it down took the foot off the gas
foot's off the gas already at this point
this goes from minus 372 to minus 70 to
-27
so the sellers that were here earlier
they're gone already
right and you're seeing now you're
basically you're seeing aggressive
buying start to creep in plus five plus
27 plus 47.
so
you know this the selling was strong on
the way down
then you got a very strong one but then
it just got weaker weaker weaker than
stronger stronger stronger right so what
do you expect the market to do you know
the selling's been removed from the
market and now you see the buying come
in that's why the market rallied
okay so
again crude oil um this was on monday
right we
hit the swing high here
came off rallied right back up towards
that high
and then dropped off
okay
now
one thing you know when markets take out
highs
or you know recent highs
you expect the buying to get stronger
right if you're going to take out a high
you want to do it on healthy volume that
that's increasing right that's getting
stronger
instead we're coming back up towards
that high
and you're seeing
the delta in this bar is 126. this bar
is only 31. this bar is 19.
okay
well if we're going to take out this
swing high here
you'll sort of want to see it in the
opposite direction you want to see
a you know strong you know a positive
delta a stronger positive delta and even
stronger positive delta as you take out
those highs and you keep going higher
instead you're seeing
the buying sort of dropping off
you know it's imagine you know i'm out
and everyone you know there's a big rush
of people you know
running up the side of the hill to get
to the top but you know as people keep
going higher there's people dropping off
dropping off and that's what you're
seeing here you're seeing the buyers
drop off drop off
then
what happens
the sellers come in you got a nice
strong negative delta minus 63
minus 104
you know minus 55
and then boom minus 182.
the strongest delta
positive or negative on this whole page
this whole chart
so you know sellers are definitely in
control by here but really the sign was
as the market was going up up up
the buyers were getting less less less
so you know if buyers are getting less
less less as the market's going up
markets probably not going to go up much
higher and it didn't
sellers came in and the market dropped
so
that's a basic way of using
delta to analyze you know sort of market
strength market weakness you know the
direction of the market
and you know again if
if if sometimes if if you're not sure
you know
which way the market's going look at the
delta see who's in control is one side
getting stronger is one side getting
weaker because at the end of the day you
know you want to be on the side
of strength
not necessarily on the side of weakness
right you want to buy strength cell
weakness
now point of control
is
it's very interesting tool and you know
it's it's fascinating because you know
every bar has a point of control
right and we're all familiar with how
candlesticks form right or bar charts
form right every bar there's an open
there's a high there's a low there's a
close but really that's just the surface
there's volume that's traded within the
bar right you can't deny that there's
volume traded in the bar
but not all prices are the same that's
like saying well you know i have a car
and you have a car they're the same
because they're cars well sometimes the
cars are bigger sometimes the cars are
smaller you know if these two cars met
head-on
who do you think is going to be the
survivor in a crash well the bigger car
just as you know volume in the market
small volume runs into big volume big
volume is going to win out okay and
again you know that's sort of a trap
that a lot of people fall into is is
trading all traded prices the same
not all prices are traded the same some
trade a lot of volume some trade
a little bit of volume
this is yesterday right this is crude
oil right market sold off
okay
and this nice little sell-off here from
you know the 8780 area
down into the
you know 87 30-ish area then it's just
sort of went sideways
okay
now what happened next was the market
rallied right it rallied about 50 cents
and you know as a trader right
when you're facing
this situation here market selling off
looks like potentially could
go sideways it did is it going to
rally or is it going to sell off
okay because
you know eventually you're going to come
out of the sideways action
and
in yesterday's instant it did rally
but
you want clues right you you want
something clear that you could wrap your
head around and understand that hey you
know what
yeah this market looks like it's about
to rally
and you're going to get it in the order
flow
specifically the point of control right
the point of control is the price level
where the most volume traded
okay and
you're seeing here right this you're
coming down you hit this
swing low here
you're getting three point controls more
or less the same price i mean this one
is one tick lower
and then when the controls start
migrating higher right when you see
volume
migrate higher move higher right again i
just sort of explained it on the delta
part right when you when your market is
going up right you're going to do it on
on generally on a healthy volume just as
if a market is going down you can do it
on healthy volume now in the bar there's
volume
okay and if the price level with the
most volume
keeps going higher it means more and
more traders
are transacting at higher prices and if
more people are transacting at higher
prices you expect the market to keep
going up just as if a market is selling
off it's looking for areas
where there's liquidity in the market
where people can transact
right and
again every bar has a point of control
and if you start seeing the point of
controls
higher in each bar higher higher higher
higher that's your sign now you don't
have to wait for you know one two three
four
five six seven eight bars of higher
point of controls to start realizing you
know what this
market is starting to rally
when you're in a sideways market you're
generally going to see point of control
sort of aligned right again these are
not perfectly aligned there's one one
tick lower
but you got two out of three
at the same price and the other one is
one tick lower then you see point of
control higher
higher higher that's your clue this
market could potentially
have reached its
bottom here or swing low
and is starting to migrate higher the
volume is starting to migrate higher and
you should start to expect higher prices
okay so somewhere to get in would be in
this bar
right and then what happens market jumps
up even if you got in late here in this
after this bar meaning you get in on
this bar you know you're still catching
you know a decent move
you know 20 cent move there i mean
ideally you should be getting in
somewhere in here or here
you know getting in you know below 50
and right in it at least up into the 70s
now again i talked about wednesday's
reopen right the five o'clock reopen
and
it was just
a big run up over 45 minutes right we
opened up you know around the the
43-10-ish area i think it was 0-8 or so
and then we just rallied
basically straight line you know
straight 45-degree angle up right up and
all the way i think it was up to 60.
but
what's the clearest to sign i'll talk
about point uh imbalances later that's
another clear sign but you're seeing
point of control
point of control higher higher higher
higher higher higher higher higher
higher higher higher higher you know
every point of control is coming in
higher
well
again you don't need to wait till after
10 point controls
migrate higher once you start seeing it
happen higher higher higher that's your
clue already you know you don't have to
you see one two three maybe four go for
it right
you know that where you can hide behind
are the previous point of controls
because
volume is generally going to act as
support
or resistance right if the market's
moving up look for point of controls
which is your bar with i'll show you the
price level with the most volume is
going to act as support and you can see
how it came right back within a tick
here
with a tick here
it got through here by a couple ticks
same price level same price level a
couple ticks higher one tick through it
again you can see how the point controls
are acting as support as this market
keeps going up and up and up
so that was you know that was an easy
one
all right now here right market's
selling off this is
tuesday um you know around 10 in the
morning in s ps
lower point controls prices migrating
lower or volume rather is migrating
lower with price you know the area where
a lot of people can trade in each bar is
getting subsequently lower lower lower
then it hits a low now it starts turning
starts going back up
right now sudden instead of point of
controls going lower they're starting to
go higher higher higher
and again you can just you know these
two are more or less the same you know
you got to give it a little bit of
leeway you'd love it to be the exact
same price or higher but you know within
a tick or two is fine but you're ready
you know that it shifted
right lowers
point control is going lower on the way
down now it's starting to go higher on
the as the market starts creeping back
up and again again you can start seeing
the deltas positive you know that's
another clue
but the deltas
and
point of controls are telling you now
buying is coming to the market people
are looking to transact at higher prices
and the market again puts in a nice
you know
15 20 point rally within the next 10
minutes
okay now
if you're looking just at the point of
controls
you're seeing a few things in here right
now again it's a little choppy in here
but then you're starting to see
higher higher higher then just sort of
goes sideways
runs into this area where the point of
controls are here then sort of just back
down
and higher higher higher as market goes
back up
right this is this is where they're
appearing here now again when you start
to see point of controls coming in at
the same level over
subsequent bars in this case four bars
you know that's a sign that the market
is probably going sideways
right which it did
that's and that's your sign to either
you know cut losses or you know stay in
the trade depending on how you what your
risk management is then you start to see
it here and then it starts
migrating higher again higher again
that's where you want to get in on the
trade
now you know this is fascinating in the
gold market on
wednesday morning right you had that big
bonkers move in the gold but what was
the clue
well the point of control is moving
higher
right it looked like it was going to go
higher here you got one two
two pointed controls this one this is
your
um
what do you call it
patient one
patient zero then one two and
zero one two three already now again not
all moves are going to be like this
sometimes you can just go sideways but
at least you're going to be positioned
to catch those moves like this
now
again this is yesterday in the s ps
you'll notice
come up here to a swing high
and this bar it came right back to this
level
right why didn't it go higher or come in
a little bit lower well
that's because it came right back up to
that point of control level now we've
done tests on this and it's actually
very effective
and
i wish i could come up with a a great
reasoning for it but
what we found is when
you have one bar's point of control and
then the next bar opens up far away from
it and then it comes right back to that
specific point of control
and then moves away
go with it as it starts to move away so
you can see here we opened up a two
points lower rallied right back up to
the point of control
and then had a nice sell-off right and
again it's it's an easy low risk trade
because you're trading down here you
know 44 33
your point of control is here at 35 and
a quarter
you just put an offer up here 35 and a
quarter you know stop up here one or two
ticks higher if it drops you out it
stops you out
if you get filled great you can catch a
you know a big move for um
you know 10 20 points and you're just
risking ticks right you're risking two
or three ticks to catch
you know full points which is really
what you want to do you want to be on
the right side of the risk reward ratio
now
again something very similar right
market going back and forth and that
this bar came right back to this level
and then shot up well
why that's where the point of control
got within
one tick
through it
right we opened up about a point and a
half higher came right down to it
overshot it by one tick
and reversed and one higher right so
again imagine you're just
throwing a bid in here now again it has
to open away from
the point of control because a lot of
times you know the bars open and close
around the previous bar's point of
control
more or less
but when it opens away comes back tests
it and then moves away from it that's
your sign that's your trade
again very similar why does the bar come
right back to this level because that's
where the point of control was this was
yesterday after the fed announcement
right remember you had the fed
announcement market shot up
came back it came off a little bit shot
back up
but then this bar came right to this
level other than puked
okay well
why that's where the point of control
was here that's where the volume was
here
right volume what people understand is
volume acts as a magnet right again
point of control is the level
in the bar with the most volume
and it's the level where in that time
period
if you're looking at a one minute chart
a five minute chart where traders found
a fair price in other words the value
level in the bar
so hopefully you can see how easily
using order flow point of control can
enhance your trading
okay so
the last thing i want to talk about is
imbalances okay and you know we're all
familiar with the term imbalances right
markets move from balance to imbalance
and
you could see here again this is on that
move monday sorry tuesday night after
the reopen right we shot up from you
know 4308 all the way up up to about 70.
you see in the green bars right then
you're seeing the red bars well
you see one red bar another red bar
you're not thinking that oh you know
what this market is going to fall over
because you just had a 50-point rally
60-point rally almost and
what you want to see you want to see
clues in the market
that
this market is is probably going to fall
over
and as you're looking at the order flow
what are you seeing mine imbalances
that's the blue numbers in the bar
versus the black
blue means buying it balances in the
two-way auction
it hits the high and then all of a
sudden you see selling imbalances come
in right doesn't get any easier than
that
right
where are your buying balances now as
you start moving down you don't get many
i mean this bar had four but
it's being overrun by selling imbalances
so on the way up you're seeing the
buying balances
on the way down you're seeing the
selling imbalances
okay now
when there's sideways market activity
oftentimes you're going to see both
buying and selling balances you're going
to see both
you're often going to see them in the
same bar
but
when they start to appear directionally
in a bar
that's your sign to go with that move
now i'm going to show you an easy way to
see imbalance the imbalances shift
okay because you know i i admit you know
sometimes i get lazy too i don't want to
analyze every single print that's going
through in the order flow i want an
easier way you know that's one of the
reasons why we created the order flows
trader software and what we do is the
same chart that i just showed you would
put a box around the bars that have
multiple imbalances not necessarily
stacked in balances but you know three
or more imbalances in a direction in a
bar right if it's a red bar it's going
to have three or more selling imbalances
if it's a green up bar it's going to
have three or more buying imbalances
and again if you're just looking here
you're not making heads or tails but now
so you see the market makes sense oh i
just hit a swing high
right here now i've got multiple selling
imbalances coming in here and here
and the market just falls over
right again it's it's keep it simple
right don't make trading it's so complex
this is crude oil
all right this is monday right that nice
move up from 8240 all the way up to you
know
83 over 83
and what are you seeing in here
multiple buying imbalances multiple
buying and balances multiple buying and
balances multiple buying and balances as
the market's moving higher now again i
mean you can sort of read what's
happening in the delta you know maybe
point of controls are a bit mixed you
know you're getting some you know
migrating higher migrating lower
migrating higher but then when you start
adding it together you're seeing delta
increase here 27 41 66 you're seeing
point of controls migrate higher
then you see the bar with the multiple
buying imbalances coming in
that's your sign you should be long
already
right
again it
don't make trading more difficult than
it needs to be
now here you've got you know sideways
action multiple buying imbalances okay
maybe you take a long but then it's met
two bars later
with multiple selling imbalances
and the market falls over so even though
you maybe you turn the bullish here okay
but then the bearish information came
into the market you know and as a trader
you have to be able to make that jump
from
bullish to bearish if the order flow
changes
and it did changed right here two bars
later
and you caught a nice move down right so
maybe you turned bullish here but then
bearish information came into the market
you got to take advantage of that don't
get married to your position
right it's another example came down
into a swing low
start point control start migrating
higher multiple buying imbalances in
here and the market started going back
up multiple buying balances multiple
buying imbalances
so
you know multiple imbalances occur
every trading day in pretty much every
market
but you need a way to see them quickly
so you can potentially trade them once
you put them in context of the market
you know and everything that you see
should be taken in context of the market
don't just go blindly buying every bar
that's got multiple buying and balances
or multi or selling everybody's got
multiple selling and bounces put it in
context of the market
and again that's where
having software that's going to you know
highlight this stuff to you it's going
to give you an edge over other traders
and the way i like to describe it is
it's like having a metal detector so you
can discover things no one else sees
right in other words you're going to see
what's happening in the two-way auction
that other traders are not seeing and
more importantly they're not reacting to
so
you know over the last 40 minutes or so
hopefully you can agree that there's
been time well spent right again i can't
cover everything in a quick training
session you know i i wish i could but i
can't you know if you're interested more
in order flow you can always go to my
youtube channel i've got several hundred
videos up there
um but i got a special offer so you can
get everything you need to know about
order flow and if you act fast i'm gonna
give you a very special deal so you're
going to be excited to know that the
order flow trader software which runs on
ninjatrader 8
and comes with
a volume footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed orderful tools now i only
talked about one of them the multiple
imbalance tools but we got tools for
seeing market weakness
we got tools for seeing market sweeps
we got tools for seeing you know price
acceptance price rejection market
exhaustion you know a lot of different
tools that are going to help you take
your trading to a next level and you
know best of all you don't need you know
the load templates or anything like that
you know we set it up so you could just
you know once you install ninjatrader
you just import and open up a chart and
add the order flow trader software to it
and your charts will look
just like mine and normally we sell it
for 8.99 but you're not going to pay
that today now the best way i can
describe it is
it's really like taking my trading
knowledge you know what i've gained over
you know 25 years working at you know
top level investment banks jp morgan you
know commerce bank trading firms cargill
edf man even on the trading floor at the
cme and putting it into a program so you
can see what you know the institutional
traders are doing in the market
but i realize though having software is
one thing you still got to know how to
use it so i don't just give you software
and send you on your way i hate that i
buy software sometimes and there's
literally no documentation
on on how to use it it's just sort of
you know
trading water though is this what i want
to do
um
you know is this how i'm supposed to use
it and we give you
a lot of education on how to read the
order flow
so you're going to get
access to my order flow trading course
which i sell for 297. you're going to
get access to that for free
but more importantly i'll take you on a
higher level i'll give you access to my
order flow
inner circle video series
which normally i sell for 497 and
there's 56 videos on advanced order flow
tips and analysis i say tricks but you
know it's really ways to analyze the
order flow that very few people know of
and you start adding all that up
together right it's close to seventeen
hundred dollars now i realize it's one
thing to learn from videos and books but
it takes discipline it takes commitment
you know we've all been down this route
we've all bought courses
not just on trading but you know maybe
other things and we never complete them
you know we watch the first couple
videos and just give up and what i found
to be very helpful
is live training where you can ask
questions and for the last three years
i've been hosting every tuesday night
live user training sessions where i
drive home when i saw on the order flow
for the past week you could ask
questions you can send me charts i'll
discuss them you know on this
training session
now
the archives i have an archive for this
so if you can't attend you can always
watch the replay there's already 152
episodes okay
and you know there's people that want to
sell you software then charge you extra
on on how to use it you know this is a
place where if you have any questions
for anything you could just come in
there ask me the questions
and again i i talk about
different forms of analysis different
ways you can use order flow than you
probably thought possible you start
adding all that together
you know it looks expensive 18 you know
over 1800
but just for a one-time payment 749 you
can get all of that
all right so just go to orderflows.com
slash off three
and it'll take you to this page
you just scroll down to the bottom
all right you just scroll down on the
side
you can see the buy button here you just
click on that takes you to paypal paypal
processes your payment i don't get your
credit card information i don't want it
and then within you know once the
payment is processed you know we'll send
you all the details for the download um
you know your license key you know
access to the courses everything
so again you just got to go to excuse me
orderflows.com3.html
i put the link in the chat there
and you know as a special bonus because
anna keeps having me back which i
appreciate
i'll give you access to the order flow
playbook for free normally i sell this
for 297 dollars but in this playbook
right it's you know it's a course on
trading but also
i jump in deeper on order flow analysis
and i teach you um you know 10
additional trade setups that you can
look for in the market
so to get started again go to
orderflows.com3.html
i put the link in the chat
and you're going to get the order flows
trader software which is normally valued
at 8.99 you get to access the overflow
trading course which is 297. i sell this
every day for 297. you get the access to
inner circle video series for 497.
that's included right you can't get
access to that any other way
you get access to the weekly live group
training
again you know people charge up to 200 a
month for
live training you get it for free you
know i got people in there that have
been using my software for
three years
they're coming in there still right it's
great and you get access to the order
flow playbook right again it's normally
it's 297 you can get it for free so
again it's just one time payment right
there's no recurring payments i'm not
going to you know hit you up on your
credit card each month now of course you
will have to pay your data fees and
ninja trader fees if you're trading
through ninjatrader
but again it's a great deal
and you know if you want to delve deeper
into order flow my book is available to
download go to orderflows.com
book.html enter your name
first last name and your email
then hit submit okay then it's going to
take you to that next page where you can
download the pdf so you get started now
just go to orderflows.com3.html
and i think i've run out of time so anna
thanks for having me
it's been my pleasure and i'll give it
back to you
thank you